we focused on making neural networks be
more biologically accurate so one of the
specific projects that I worked on was
implementing latency between neurons and
implementing spike neuronal spiking
where brain neurons really don't have a
gradient of a value between say 0 & 1
it's either on or off the research to
make these kinds of neural networks for
neurons either on or off is very real I
was very happy to be at the cutting edge
of this kind of research so my project
right now is making these kinds of cells
for oxytocin we have a very good sales
for vasopressin and now we want to make
these kinds of sensors for oxytocin this
will be very useful to see where these
neurotransmitters actually move in the
brain and this will allow us to study
the brain more in depth know someone's
opinion me contradict yours what my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we if what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everybody welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Sathyan we are on-site
in the beautiful Beijing China at the
Peking University School of Life
Sciences we are now going to be talking
with anthony simon off hello nice to
meet you again I guess thank you very
much for having me on your show very
excited to be here
you're so often brother I'm so pumped
for this absolutely it's gonna be great
yeah it's great to meet you it's so cool
knowing that you were coming here from
Chicago over the summer to do and
research here at PKU and it was great to
meet you and so I'm pumped for this
convo those who don't know Nancy's
background he's a researcher in the Lee
lab at Peking University School of Life
Sciences focused on engineering
florescent sensors for neurotransmitters
and you can find the links in the bio
below to you lonely lab org as well as
LinkedIn profile all right let's start
things off by asking one of our favorite
questions what are your thoughts on the
direction of our
I have yeah there's a variant as I'm
sure you know very broad topic so I'll
touch on a few things that I think about
it you like the world I guess is like
for me what I think about it is the
direction that people are giving it
giving to it excuse me so what that
means is like it and all of us
collectively like where are we going
well I don't know if anyone really knows
we have kind of scientific stuff that
we're doing we're doing other well
especially for me because I'm a
researcher there's also a cultural and
musical and all of the other kinds of
experiences that people are doing and
living and constructing on a daily basis
which I hope are for done for a good
cause and they've all allow people to
live happier healthier and better lives
in the future
so in long story short I think direction
of the world is for a more prosperous
more peaceful kind of society where
people are just live happier lives more
fulfilling what do you think is the core
skill that we should embody to make sure
it's peaceful and harmonious and move
forward I don't think there is one
specific skill that we say okay everyone
you need to learn how to be a be a
farmer I let everyone ruthless be what a
good person but there's not one specific
skill all right at least be nice little
kind maybe
yeah be yeah absolutely of course
disagreements always have existed in
human history but it's how we overcome
those disagreements and what we do in
order to peacefully establish some kind
of resolution that will really make a
difference I feel in the future yeah
let's see hit your journey so you're
born in Chicago yes sir and you picked
up piano when you were like five is that
right yeah actually right uh when I was
four technically it's over
that time I've been playing ever since
it's been an amazing journey for the
fest what 14 years now yeah 14 years of
piano playing since there were 4 years
old ok and then yeah how does this all
end up happening that you would pick up
music when you're young then you pick up
your interest in science and computer
science so tell us about who you were
when you were young and how you pick
those things up well for piano it was
mostly my parents because no you know
little toddler wants to sit and play
piano for hours a day so that I don't
have to ascribe to my parents and thank
you for introducing me to this world of
music for kind of neuroscience and
machine learning the kinds of other
stuff that I've done I've always been
interested in the brain I read a great
book called Goodell Escher Bach by
Douglas Hofstadter it's we really opened
my eyes to the possibilities of you know
exploring the brain and exploring the
kind of computer science aspects of it
so especially over the course of my
childhood I would read more kind of
science fiction novels to see bravery
like do you see where artificial
intelligence and similar technologies
could go and then once I get to college
I was able to actually work in a lab
modelling making my models for the human
brain which was very exciting so then
when you got to college you pick
neuroscience yeah so the University of
Chicago does not unfortunately have an
artificial intelligence major so I chose
the next best thing which is to be a
neuroscience major as well as focusing
on computer science in my free time it's
more involved with me working in a lab I
worked in David Friedman's computational
neuroscience lab we focused on making
neural networks be more biologically
accurate so one of the specific projects
that I worked on was implementing
latency between neurons and implementing
spike neuronal spiking which is really
what happens in the brain where brain
neurons really don't have a gradient of
a value between say 0 & 1
it's either on or off and the research
to make these kinds of neural networks
where neurons are either on or off is
very new
and I was very happy to be at the
cutting edge of this kind of research
alright let's unpack this more this is a
interesting aspect to our conversation
so let's start by explaining what do you
mean neural networks and biology how do
you see those things what is their
relationship I think in in the past and
even up to now neural networks all right
well they're called neural networks
they're based on human brains their
purpose is to learn there they have
singular units called neurons and
they're very similar to the brain in a
lot of ways and very different and even
more so what they're similar because
they're neurons that are connected and
we can model with some areas of the
brain relatively well unfortunately we
don't understand the brain well enough
to model all of it yeah and this
similarity is so and that's about where
the similarities to the biological side
end I feel so you have the for neural
network so you can process way more data
than a brain can because they're built
in computers and as computing power
grows it will only grow in size and
strengthened and complexity so this is
where you get the fears of AI taking
over the world from the matrix to Elon
Musk's recent tweets so you have this
kind of once you have this kind of super
intelligent second process and do way
more data computationally than a human
kitten there's a you can take over the
world we are nowhere near there yet but
it's a possibility all right so let's
revisit the structure of this so we
artificially create a neural network in
a computer yes yeah okay so these are
models there where their backbone is a
lot of linear algebra where it's just
pure math so the most do typical example
is you feed it a handwritten number and
then the network will output whether he
thinks numbers zero through nine which
is actually way harder to do
programmatically than you'd expect which
is why this has only been a recent
development
okay so let's walk us through that
example so then one
right the number two on a little sheet
of paper and then I take an image of it
and then I feed it through the neural
network the first thing that it's doing
is its scanning it pixel by pixel like
what is it what is it doing and then how
is it creating an idea of what the
answer is yeah so neural networks the
yes so in essence that's what's
happening you you're taking it this
little picture I think it's 16 by 16
pixels I could be off but yeah it's it
takes this picture and then they're the
neural networks have what are called
hidden layers so they're layers where
you don't really know what they're doing
you might hypothetically think that oh
if we have three of these hidden layers
the first one will look at kind of where
the pixels are arranged on the screen
the second rule for maybe a curve at the
top or like the straight line at the
bottom and then the third layer will
combine all the this information
together and then output the information
that it sees but we don't actually know
if this is what's happening we obviously
you can analyze it but just by looking
at the neural network itself you have we
have no idea how it makes these
calculations so yes to answer your
question you it scans that pixel by
pixel or I'm sorry it stores all of
these pixels in some kind of memory
format and then does a bunch of
calculations on these pixels with
certain weights and biases within these
hidden layers and then outputs a
probability of what the sensor is so it
would say okay I think that it's a one
with maybe one percent probability and a
zero with two percent probability but I
think it's a two with a 97 percent
probability or there's a 97% chance that
this is a two and that's how you train
this neural network to get and give you
a good answer
mmm so the hidden layers are doing some
sort of analysis on the image yes yeah
and then you have to Train those hidden
layers to do these specific aspects of
the analysis yeah so it's like an if
curve than this mmm stuff like that what
is it what is it like then not and not
really it's not if curve than this
hidden layers that they're caught hidden
because they do whatever they want and
the way you train these hidden layers is
you okay at the end maybe because those
if-then statements are like hard the
hard coded yeah hard coded and you these
you have to be really flexible with
these hidden layers you there's gonna be
tons of examples of what that curve can
look like so it's not gonna be just an
if-then yeah yeah so the way it works is
an algorithm called back propagation
where you feed then say you write a 2
and you feed it to the network and then
the network says it's a 5 and you're
like well no this is a 2 and I want you
to lower this error and the way this
error lowering works is there's a
gradient kind of it doesn't what's
called the gradient descent and it goes
down this kind of gradient of
probabilities and eventually if you did
enough numbers and it will go down kind
of low enough in this like inverse
parabola to the low point where the
probabilities are where the
probabilities have little error and so
that's where you get the accurate
answers ok so back propagation is
telling the neural network that you are
you were wrong and then we need to tweak
a certain hidden layer yes in order to
increase efficiency yeah pretty much
ok ok and then when you do the tweaking
is it a what does the tweaking of a
hidden layer look like is it changing
the linear algebra the math is that what
you're saying well the math is
essentially the same it's changing the
values these values in a math in the
math yeah so each each neuron has what's
called a weight and a bias so a weight
is a number that you multiply the input
by so for example if my input is 5 and
my weight is 2 of n it multiplied by 2
and I get a time and a bias is where you
add on to this final value so if my so 5
times 2 is 10 and then say my bias is 3
right so then
10 plus 3 so then my value of the snare
on after whatever inputs go into it is a
10 which was 2 so 2 times 5 yeah so your
input was 2 and your output was 13
yes and so what was the significance of
weights and biases well I used large
numbers too as an easy example all of
these numbers would actually between be
between 0 & 1
yeah so the purpose of these meanings 0%
or 100% is that's only for the last hour
like the answer and for the it's not
really percentage it's just a value
between 0 & 1 for all the hidden layers
up until the last layer yeah so each
yeah so with each kind of input and
weight of what it means is that the this
specific neuron out of however many
hundreds you have can change kind of the
data flowing through it it changes it
either up or down and then by the time
that flows through all of these hundreds
of neurons by the end of just through
ten neurons you or tonight then that's
where you have the kind of probability
scale of this is not this number not
this number but it's this one kind of
thing okay so my values in the math are
where I change weights and biases yes on
all the neurons yeah and then so back
propagation there's also this thing this
thing called a cost function or a loss
function which is kind of how far you
are away from the actual answer and back
propagation is a kind of tool that
blowers this the value of the loss
function so your error is less and it
does this by going back up the hidden
layers and tweaking the weights and
biases in such a way as to lower the
loss function value pretty much so I can
make an algorithm that will go and tweak
the math to make it so that my answers
are more efficient yes yeah and then you
feed it hundreds over thousands of
examples and then by the end it becomes
very good at analyzing oh this is a 2 or
a 5 or a cat or a dog or whatever Google
is doing nowadays
so the first example we gave was like
imagenet where it's numbers and in
pictures yes yeah
and now that's already classifying at
unprecedented rates obviously with
greater efficiency than humans do due to
shear we'd sleep eight hours we get
hungry we get emotional we can only do
one at a time exactly yeah so there's
also different different kinds of
technologies like for example with
speech translation or speech recognition
for a Alex and Syria also built on
similar kinds of networks so that is
actually the same thing obviously more
complex so the natural language
processing also takes something like the
word mom yeah and then it feeds that
into a neural network that has hidden
layers that is trying to yeah take the
audio that I emitted mm-hmm that sound
wave yeah so if you say for example hey
Siri call mom and I'm sorry to any of us
who actually called mom right now
actually the device at home actually
calls mom or even better maybe you
should call your mom right now yeah tell
her you love her right now that would be
a great idea okay so when I say hey like
Sora hey Siri call mom what what it does
is it takes the sound wave and it does a
bunch of they did all the peaks and
valleys and analyzes all of this data
and then by the end after you know all
of this math that was put on it and I
don't know the details
I don't think Amazon or Apple will ever
ever let us know anything exact details
of what happens by the end it could
sends the commands to your phone to call
your mom right so this is this obviously
so it was a long way to go as a lot of
people are still don't well I like some
serious so obviously aren't perfect and
but it's come a really long way to
especially in the past it's a few years
yeah so
the first thing is then it would take
this call or call or call yeah and so
there's all these different ways to say
it but then that that first command is
there it's like okay with 90% accuracy
we know he said call and then the second
word was mom yeah okay and then so then
it's fine so this is this is hmm this is
tough so then it's feeding the data from
the peaks and the valleys of the sound
wave through the neural network in the
neural network is then analyzing with
weight and bias on different neurons
going through the hidden layers that
this is this it might be a different
kind of style of doing all that work
instead of just having layers and
numbers and biases what are the
different styles of neural networks so
I'll just list a few the most the the
one that most people think about and
which is the one you hear about and like
introduction to neural networks 101
class is what's called a convolutional
neural network you have an input layer
of however many neurons and you have
hidden layers each have over many
neurons so then you have an output layer
so they're kind of stacked one on top of
another now the other kind the one then
it goes through linearly yes yeah and it
just goes forward and then the back
propagation goes backwards there's no
communication between neurons in the
same layer convolutional neural networks
and neurons don't talk to each other in
the same layer yes okay you just move
the data from the first layer to the
second through those hidden layers yeah
out the yeah so there's no communication
and vertically for initially yeah one
style of neural network that does allow
for this communication is what's called
the recurrent neural network so you have
your input layer and then you feed your
data into like a good way to describe it
is kind of like imagine a box where all
of the neurons are connected to each
other and they all talk to each other
and then you iterate on this box a few
times and then you
put it so this is it's called a brick
crank because all of the neurons are
talking to each other in this kind of
box so it would be like if the
convolutional neural network would hit
like one of the hidden layers and then
say hey hold on slow down let's go back
to the second hidden layer and and that
would be more like what a recurrent
neural network would be doing would be
having those neurons talking to each
other to produce the best answer instead
of go through it linearly actually very
very close yeah so this is basically
having a convolutional neural ulbrich
not so see I have two hidden layers that
go backwards but just talk within one
layer to itself only lengthen one layer
and then okay yeah interesting so the
box is one layer one layer and you can
have multiple of these boxes but that's
usually not necessary well it depending
on what kind of task you want so each
layer could be its own recurrent neural
network yet box yeah with you which is
unnecessary or which it just requires a
lot more computing power yeah it
increases with each box you have yeah
yeah yeah and so GPUs are the best or TP
use now are the best
so either graphics processing units or
specifically I forget what TPU sensor
that I tensor processing unit is what
which are specifically designed for this
kind of large scale matrix
multiplication of for machine learning
in David Friedman's lab we used I think
826 T C is in one computer to run our
networks so pretty much top-of-the-line
graphics cards there weren't GPUs but
they were very good okay so now what did
you do with these recurrent and
convolutional neural networks which one
did you use and what were you doing in
the lab at your Chicago and then we'll
talk about what you're doing here
yeah of course so most of my project
during the school year focused on
implementing latency between each neuron
and mint in the models that we were
building so in in a co2 pikal neural
network each neuron just instantly well
as instantly as possible on a computer
instantly communicates to each network
to each neuron down the line however in
the brain this isn't actually the case
and for your brain neurons to
communicate it takes about 10 to 40
milliseconds for the signal to travel
from one neuron to another so one of the
projects I worked on what the other
members of the lab was implementing this
kind of late random ish latency between
each neuron and in the end it we
implemented it it didn't exactly lead to
well no it led to better results in the
specific tasks we were going for another
project I worked on was implementing
complex numbers into one of our neural
networks unfortunately this didn't
exactly work out in our implementation
for whatever reason but we so these are
the kinds of experiments we try in order
to make these there has to be more
biologically accurate so there's a 10 to
40 second Millis 10 to 40 millisecond
latency between neurons communicating in
our brain yes ok and then in a neural
network it's even less than that in an a
and if you don't implement this kind of
latency it's basically each neuron just
communicates as fast as possible as much
as possible whatever your time the step
constant is oh and then you can add a
latency paradigm to that layer and say
that hey you have to do this in less
than 10 milliseconds yes you can do that
we specifically said you we would
specifically make neurons basically hit
pause would be like okay you have to do
this in 35 milliseconds or 20
milliseconds whatever the specific
whatever for this specific neuron
whatever the value was so it just makes
it slower and mm-hmm which and which is
good for recurrent neural nurses and it
maybe takes us time to figure out if
it's the right not
Sara this isn't necessarily good for if
you want fast neural network kind of
outputs what we were focusing on a lot
making these networks be more
biologically accurate and having this
Telus stuff about the brain okay for
example one of the recent papers out of
the Friedman lab which was before my
time but it probably was published in
June in Nature Neuroscience was that
the researchers found by implementing a
different kind of biological process
they actually found that memories stored
in two different places in the brain
which is very and one of those places is
very hard to measure in an actual human
brain because one of these places is
synaptic strengths between neurons and
this kind of strength is difficult if
not impossible to measuring because you
can't really take a brain apart and look
at each of the connection strengths so
by making these kinds of biological kind
of testing grounds we or lab similar to
David Friedman's and of course David
Freese and so I was to actually learn
more about the human brain as well so
what would be then aspects of neural
network engineering that would give you
these insights into how we store memory
in our biology how did that how did
those discoveries work so we we the
researcher is specifically Nick mass was
the first author of the paper and his
team and focused made it had a
hypothesis that the working memory so it
basically like short-term memory is
stored in both neuronal strengths so
excuse me yeah neuronal strengths which
is how strong does your neuron fire and
how often an synaptic efficacy z' which
is the strengths of the connections
between neurons and through a lot of
math which I don't really know off the
top of my head they were managed to
implement both of these proud
he's in neural networks and trained them
on specific tasks and what they found
was in order to just memorize
information in short-term memory
synaptic strengths are used so the
strengths between each term not the
neuron itself with the strengths between
different neurons but in order to kind
of manipulate this information so I see
something and I think about it or even
or even remember it so that involves the
neurons themselves which is kind of
understandable yeah cool cool ok and now
the ideas that we can then do other
forms of neural network engineering to
take get insights about how our
biological brains work yeah
yeah this is absolutely just one example
of many others that are currently out
there and what are you interested in
doing with neural network engineering
and you gave another example of you guys
were doing you were trying to implement
you said real numbers into complex
numbers complex numbers into yeah so
there's a real part and an imaginary
part so the real part is just a number
like we're usually and well you're used
to thinking about so like zero through
one zero through one in all the decimals
yes is the reals that's the real CS and
then the imaginary part is another value
from zero to one times I and I is the
square root of negative one so that's
what makes it imagining and in some
implementations of in the literature
that we found in some employment agency
size for better kind of a better and
faster and neural network processing
however in Ironton what our
implementation that I worked on this
didn't really work there's a whole slew
of reasons why this might have failed
and we're not really sure what exactly
just in our specific implementation
these complex numbers did not work okay
I remember there was something crazy
that I was learning about yeah what is
it square root of negative I 1 negative
1 yeah that's just I like where root of
negative 1 is I yeah yeah and then I
think there was like something else
after that
like the quaternions and not Tony
answers
learning about that it was so crazy yeah
there's a bunch of of these little like
weird mathematical idiosyncrasies that
computer scientists and mathematicians
and physicists like Tom cover yeah and
hopefully give us insight into the world
so okay so now yes let's talk about
neural network engineering for
biological purposes so yeah what do you
what do you want to see happen in that
in that field where do you see it going
right now what are you one doing it I
think the be-all end-all
would be to be actually able to simulate
an actual human brain within a computer
however the human brain has many many
neurons in the order of hundreds in the
order of millions I think hundreds of
thousands to millions with the order of
trillions of connections between them
and we simply do not have the computing
power do you first so even be able to
scan a human brain to this kind of
granularity and second well to be able
to simulate this human brain with all of
its different connections once we've
scanned it so neurotransmitters yeah and
especially of all of the other cells
that are in the brain that helped the
didn't neurons do what they do some of
which help sickly neurotransmitters
others kind of deliver blood and if you
have a stroke than those kinds of then
those neurons near there are impaired so
I hope that in the near future the this
would be a possibility and this will
allow us to really understand the human
brain so much better excite once we can
simulate it and play around with it
Claire and with a simulated brain but
we're still very far from that there's
been recent papers that unfortunately I
forgot the first author of that I have
simulated a lot of neurons however I
think it was still only on the scale of
10% I'm an actual human brain so we're
coming close a lot Wow
yeah we're coming closer but we're still
very far away and I hope that I'll be
able to take part in all of this how did
you decide to come out picking
University the summer
so the University of Nevada has a great
program called the Metcalf program and
the MEC have program among all of its
other benefits University of Chicago
students allows will pay students to go
out to unpaid internships and I was
interested in going to China Jibson and
traveling and studying abroad and I
applied through a handshake which is the
kind of my job search platform that
University of Chicago uses it was some
of the universities I applied to
definitely his lab and after in an
interview process with Lachlan who was
one of the students here I was able to
come out here and the University of
Chicago that might have program sponsors
my trip out here which really is what
makes it all possible yeah interesting
sub Metcalf program so you have
potentially you can have wealthy donors
or patrons from around the world that
sponsor young people to go out over the
summers to different parts of the world
and meet people and do research there
and yeah make cultural ties happen yeah
absolutely that yeah so it's not any
kind of internship so what uh whatever
you're interested in the you know the
mecca program within certain criteria
obviously will sponsor your trip
overseas or if you want to stay in
Chicago and work in one of the labs
there that anything I have any kind of
work experience and then how about
engineering florescent sensors for
neurotransmitters this is what you're
doing right now in the lab what does
that mean so we like when the cell
receives the neurotransmitter at
flores's exactly yeah so we have certain
proteins called GP Sarah's green
fluorescent proteins which or sorry G of
peas green fluorescent proteins which
they light up when there are certain
neurotransmitters being in the vicinity
or inside the cell so though my project
right now is making
there's these kinds of sells for proxy
to--some we have very good sales for
vasopressin and now we want to make
these kinds of sensors for oxytocin this
will be after this kind of radar in this
age the this will be very useful to see
where it these neurotransmitters
actually move in the brain and this will
allow us to study kind of the brain more
in-depth currently I worked with e.coli
after a certain kind of testing stage
and once we have good enough sensors we
inject them into mice and then we study
these mice and in vivo and we say hello
and they respond or how their brains
respond to these kinds of chemicals see
you end up taking a decent amount of
your background how did you how did okay
I see so it's the neuroscience like
background for you because it's not too
much neural networks yeah oh yeah I'm a
computational side for you right now so
you're actually working on engineering
the sensors for oxytocin yes okay so
when a neuron receives oxytocin you're
gonna light it up with GFP is gonna
light it up yeah and so then you're you
were engineering that right now in
e.coli yes yeah so we make the we make
the proteins and we introduce them in
plasmids I don't have the e.coli Express
them and then do a bunch of imaging
tests and then see what and what are the
best candidates and repeat and go from
there okay and then and then that gets
injected into mice eventually yeah we
package them into viruses and these
viruses deliver into mice the n2 mice
not specifically yeah and then and then
how does then you have to then you image
the mouse's brain to see the
fluorescence yes for specifically
oxytocin so then it has to have some
sort of like a like a like a female
Mouse has to come up or something like
something
that were well we haven't done this or
oxytocin so and the e.coli stage but for
other kinds of sensory received either
stimulated with let's stimulate the
mouse with something or you just simply
inject the drug into the brain and see
if it works and then
so you will give us this example earlier
with the strength of simulation software
being able to make a human brain and
some teams already doing 10% of the
human brain does it feel like we're
already in a simulation especially
coming a little bit of hairy elm
I don't know I don't know if if we are
in the simulation I don't know if it's
possible to notice and even if we are in
a simulation who's to say that our
so-called creators aren't in the
simulation themselves right um it
doesn't it so these the this clip sure
yes
hypothetically we could be and we could
never know it but I don't think this is
this really affects my specific
worldview because we just don't know and
it's better to loop we've just not
assumed we are in a simulation and that
this is the real thing and kind of
experience life and from the perspective
of this is the only chance we get and
the this is the again real kind of
experience as opposed to is it of it's
not just faked and created for
somebody's research project
seems like the computation of capacities
increasing in unleashing super
intelligences in quantum computing is
gonna be enabling us to run our own
simulations of brains and of
civilizations and of all different types
of things and that's going to give us
deeper insight into our own source code
of this reality and that'll be a very
fun awakening moment for for many of us
and I don't think those things have to
be exclusive like living life with a
deep amount of meaning and passion and
then whether or not this is a simulation
yeah so you can always live life with
deep meaning and passion and purpose
regardless if it is or is not a
simulation
what would the
skill that young people should know
going into the exponential technology
age be singular skill I think privacy
it's not specifically a skill but it's a
really important mindset you have
especially with nothing that you put on
the internet really ever being deleted
and especially for my generation and the
generation right after me where
everything is recorded and everything is
always on your phones I think privacy is
a really important concern we have
scandals of Cambridge analytics
recently as well as kind of as a
antitrust in and focus on Google as well
as other big corporations now that have
a lot of our own data and what we do so
it's important to I think be
knowledgeable that about kind of what
you post on the Internet you may come
back and haunt you and bite you later
but on the other hand it's also
important now to have a healthy kind of
social life on these social networks
because the if anyone is for example an
interviewer if an interviewer is looking
for you and tries to do some kind of
background research then having these
experiences on these social networks and
kind of posting the good moments from
your life is also really important to
show that to show what you've done and
kind of what kind of person you are
mm-hmm
yeah I was good see your piano videos on
the internet yeah and your you know your
profile on LinkedIn at least gave me a
little bit more of a background on you
at the same time I like seeing people
post themselves completely transparently
like not just the good but also the
struggles and the challenges and things
like that and I myself do that yeah
absolutely
that helps a lot too shows real humanity
it shows vulnerability it shows it's
good to talk about triumphs over those
challenges because they can inspire
other people to do the same
and it's interesting thinking about
going into a completely transparent
world and it's also thinking interesting
about quantum encryption and all the
privacy safe world at the same time so
it's kind of like hmm can we build that
love trust and affinity for each other
across the world can we not need such
military budgets and regimes can we
ascend our consciousness to more
harmonized together around the planet on
that question how do you think we can
inspire people around the world to work
together to I think in and there's
different you can kind of do this
differently for different goals so if
you I think science is a really good
example of this where you have
scientists from all over the world
writing papers and reading the papers of
their peers that may not even be on the
same continent or hemisphere so you have
this huge kind of collection of people
that are indirectly working together and
I think if we have this before similar I
have similar kinds of things for other
kinds of fields of study or walks of
life I guess the this could be no it's
good lead to very good kind of outcomes
so you have maybe for say the hard case
let's say politicians right so you have
a lot of countries with competing
interests and I think if there was more
kind of transparency between the issues
of one country with another or even the
wants and desires of one country over
the other you can have reach more
peaceful resolutions going back to what
we talked about the start of this
interview of can a more communication
between parties yeah so I think it all
boils down to how the amount of
communication and transparency and
certain there is what do you think is
the overall meaning of this human
experiment well but what do you mean by
experiment No
and say I'm not experiment human
experience both of them what is the
meaning of it I think on an individual
oh I think of the meaning is what you
give it really of for example of I am
very happy studying and doing a
conducting research so the meaning it
would yeah the meaning for me might be
something along the lines of I I want to
create or I want to do more research or
I want to kind of find the answers to
these questions assistive questions
someone else who finds satisfaction and
purpose in doing other things that that
maybe their meaning of life I don't I
don't know if there is a meaning of life
for it
Sara like all of us that is the same
thing but I think on an individual but
you can definitely find something that
makes you happy and content do you think
consciousness is a biological phenomenon
I think we well yes the short answer is
yes long answer is we don't know of what
exactly consciousness is it's very hard
to define we know we have it we don't
where X don't have it probably that's
what that's what we've got
does it come it comes from the brain
wearing the brain on the brain great
open-ended questions in neuroscience
right now do you think about freewill I
like to live my life believing I do
because at least in my personal
experience I don't I choose to live as
if that my choice is really do matter
and I have that I am the one making
these choices and set some deterministic
path that I've been sent down by yeah
that I've just been sat down what do you
think is the role of love in life um
well there's many different kinds of
right there's the parental love there is
kind of fraternal or brotherly sibling
above there's obviously amorous love so
I think different kinds of love have
different kinds of roles the parental
love of or kind of in family dynamics or
very important food to kind of culture
and well-being obviously more personal
Wow
amorous relationships are also very
important what the role of love I don't
know I don't think I can classify it
into one oh this is the world of love it
should be happy I guess
maybe they don't have the answer to this
question I'm sorry this is why we ask
yeah what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world most
beautiful thing um very similar answer
there are many different kinds of beauty
I feel I'm a pianist I love listening to
other performers and musicians
especially those that are at the peaks
of a piece of their careers and we're
the best of what they do they create
beauty at their instrument there's
beauty in arts there's beauty and
culture there's you know there's beating
just people and right the mo and I don't
know if I can say of something like a
lot and so if this is the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen yeah yeah yeah you
know you're you're you're you being a
pianist is also very interesting because
in many ways that has a lot of
computational properties itself as well
there's specific notes that are played
there specific space between the notes
there's a length of the note there's
where is the note being played on the
scale there's so many aspects of the
competent torx of yeah music and that's
very similar with with computer science
or with neuroscience so it seems like
those things really meshed together well
for building out a worldview music and
science yeah we we've known this for a
while actually at the same area of the
brain that is activated when you play or
listen to music is the same air of the
brain which is activated when you do
math so doing one makes you good and
good and more precisely better
at the other as well so they're very
intimately tied and a lot of or at least
in my experience a lot of doctors that
I've known do playing kind of a playing
instrument of some sort and they're good
at it too yeah you say thanks for coming
on to our show yeah absolutely thank you
so much for having me it's super fun I
really appreciate it thing yeah thank
you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know if you're thinking
also check out the links in the bio
below you'll only lab org also his
LinkedIn profile also have more
conversations to friends families
co-workers people online about neural
networks and about neuroscience and
about the future of all these fields
have more conversations about it and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below you can
contribute to us patreon PayPal
cryptocurrency all those links are below
and also go in and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world you love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we'll see you soon
peace
to wrap my man could draw it think you
did that was all right yeah on upon yet
[Music]